I don't know if we want to talk about
conspiracy theories or anything but like
it is all of like we have the proof and
the pudding of like the 400 000 people
on payroll like all of the paperwork all
of the Oh you mean uh the the question
the conspiracy if we land on the Moon
yeah like I mean I I think the receipts
are there like literally we did but it's
like a lot of things like that I mean
we're actually generally live in a in a
pretty cynical time where people
distrust institutions part of the thing
with the space program is one of the
things that can help reinvigorate the
Trust In institutions by institutions
even that word is a bad word now but
institutions means a bunch of humans get
together and do a big thing together
yeah
um yeah but you know like if I was
conspiratorily minded It's like how the
hell did humans do that yeah
so yeah I I think that's a very cynical
take unfortunately but it's still an
incredible one and also you know there's
grow there's uh until you look at the
receipts there's a kind of
um
like a rationale to that kind of
conspiracy theory because
so much pressure was put on the Space
Race the the pr of it to be the winner
so it makes sense that you might want to
try to take shortcuts and fake things
and you know propaganda
you you know different kinds of
messaging and I'm sure stuff like that
was happening some kind of like little
you know adjustment here and there to
present things better and so on but
ultimately the actual engineering
project of landing on the moon I the
fact that humans did that I mean it is
sad that we didn't have better like ways
to record it and as I watched like
SpaceX efforts and blue origin and these
efforts
is still not trivial to record the uh
how just amazing awe-inspiring spaces
because it like
you know like it's like Elon jokes about
like his face does look fake yeah like I
think there is some element of it where
you have to be there to experience it
really and I don't like I think it's
it's currently is still an unsolved
problem of how do you capture the awe of
that I mean you're one of the early
people that are uh part of the crew that
is exploring that very question I'm sure
you won't find all the answers but
you'll start to say like how do we
convert this into a visual format into
some kind of format that captures the
the magic of it 100 and that's a
perspective thing that I think about all
the time you know when I I'll I'll do a
lot of thinking about like what is the
thing that's reacting to people is it
the sound is it the perspective is it
like seeing a little tiny human next to
a landing leg that makes people go oh my
God this thing is huge you know just
reading you know and digesting that and
trying to help
to convey that as best as possible
because the stuff that we are and have
worked on is is so cool it's so exciting
and it's so it's so important and like
actually you know
so much bigger than any one of us
physically and metaphorically it's just
so it's just I wish everyone had that
that experience and had that light bulb
go off and that's the cool thing that
you're like smack in the middle of
solving that really difficult and
fascinating problem of how how do you
capture the magic how do you inspire
like that's not just an engineering
problem that's a communication problem
education I I find specifically for
myself that I get most excited about
something when I learn a lot about it
like when I learned the ins and outs and
I learn all the little problem solving
and the you know the cool like oh my God
they had to do what to make it work wow
that's amazing and that's I try to just
always go back to that thing of like
what can I teach myself like if I'm
every video I I expect that I learned
something making it no matter what like
no matter how uh much I think I know
about something at the end of the day if
I'm not learning something it's not a
good video you know and
I always think that people get excited
when they learn and when they have uh
some questions answered for them